hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna be working with some react
components if you were with us yesterday
you know that we upgraded to the latest
version of material UI since version 1.2
point O we had a lot of breaking changes
that we had to deal with and now we're
gonna go through and we're gonna edit
some components to adjust to some of the
things that change so they weren't
exactly breaking we're not getting
errors in the console anymore but the
Styles are a little bit off now so we're
gonna change some things up and see how
far we get with that I'm thinking maybe
an hour for the stream hour and a half
depending on how many questions there
are and let me check the stream health
quickly let me know if the streams okay
it was showing that the stream health
was not good which is really weird
because everything else is showing up as
is okay so yeah just let me know if
everyone can see and hear me all right
and then if so we will get started
I'm going to get that code ready on my
other screen and then switch over
all right cool looks like it there are
no problem with one off Thank You Teresa
and Nikki okay let's switch over alright
so here's the code if you are working on
this project locally if you have a fork
or something like that of the repo if
you have any issues when you when you
pull in the latest changes delete your
node modules and then run yarn again so
I had to do that because I had some
issues and that fixed everything so
that's generally a good thing to try
when you're having some weird issues and
you're not sure why if it works it'll
save you a lot of time and you know if
it doesn't work then you know you've
you've wasted maybe you know a minute or
two depending on how fast your computer
is char Belle says don't start now no
one is here yet alright well there is
one thing I want to fill you in on so I
guess I can stall for another minute or
so I don't want to wait too long
I interviewed another potential student
worker today and he seemed really
interested in working on some of the
data cleanup so I'm hoping now that I
have like two or three you know student
workers that should be able to start
some time like in like the next two
weeks so I'm gonna stop with a lot of
the data cleanup that I've been doing
that's been taking up most of my time
and I'm gonna shift into you know
dealing a lot more with the actual react
side of things and maybe even start in
on doing some some testing using
lighthouse to try to get the site like
really fast and
get that accessibility score up as high
as I can so it may not affect the
streams and that much except that you
know they'll probably be more getting
done on the react side of things between
streams and hey everybody see rotates
here's a nice okay so yeah we gained
about five more people in that that the
last minute or so so I think we're gonna
get started it's still a little bit
lower than normal but I think it's it's
cool to get started so it's like we have
15 viewers which is definitely way lower
than normal but I mean when I started I
would have one viewer I'm fine with
streaming without very many people okay
so we do have our code up here just in
case you didn't get to watch the last
you know stream this has changed and
this is a big change so we have we now
have material UI and I'm gonna probably
remove this code mod at some point this
was help with migration but I couldn't
get it to work so we have at material UI
core and at material UI I cons and this
has replaced the other material UI
packages so we've updated to the latest
stable version and we're going to
continue with a stable version this
makes me more comfortable as we approach
going live that we're no longer on the
beta like latest release track so I was
fine with that when we were developing
but it's nice that we can switch to the
stable here before we launch alright so
and the biggest changes have just been
around this where we've had to adjust to
a lot of like the changes to the API
alright so let me let me pull over on
this screen
let me there we go
I thought we already had some local
loose open I'll get rid of this we'll
just wait for this to load there we go
and let me start my Pomodoro timer so
I'm gonna code now for about 25 minutes
and then I'll get back to the live chat
and answer some questions if you have
questions go ahead and put them in the
chat but I won't get to them for about
25 minutes if you can't stick around for
that you can always watch that's weird
let me refresh that there we go okay
that was kind of an odd odd glitch okay
so here's the first problem that I'd
like to deal with right now this may end
up being just a CSS thing so we may not
we'll see how much we have to change for
this but since we updated this is
happening and I don't want this to be an
oval it's supposed to be a circle I was
able to narrow down exactly why it's
happening basically once the window
width gets you know wide enough the
height of this element which is a button
goes to 70 pixels but the width remains
that I believe 48 pixels so then when we
have the border radius of 50% it becomes
an oval instead of a circle so what I
think we can do I think we're going to
use a little bit of flex flex box to
vertically align this and then we can
change the height so just to kind of
demonstrate why we need to do it like
that and why we can't just change the
height right away is that let's verify
that it's still an oval no it's a circle
so I need to make this and you shift
this over there we go now we have the
oval let me make this bigger so y'all
can see
and one more there we go
okay so let's select this button div and
I really want you know what let me move
this down there we go and then let me
move me up there we go now you should be
able to see this hopefully it's not too
small let me know if it is and so let's
put the hover on all the time so we're
going to activate this hover state here
and so that'll stay hover it up here and
let's zoom in so we can see if I bring
the height back down to where it is it
obviously fixes it but now this is no
longer centered it's it's up at the top
and I think it looks a lot nicer when
it's centered there so I mean what we
could do potentially is just like kind
of manually set hey let's let's make it
this many pixels from the top right we
could do that and then use the same
media query for that or we could just
try to vertically align it within its
container so I think the better solution
which will work even if we end up
changing the height of the container
sorry if you hear my stomach growling I
haven't eaten very much yet so I just I
didn't plan well and I didn't bring food
and I didn't have time to go get food so
anyway like I'd rather do the flexbox
vertical centering because that will be
better if we change things later on so
let's check out the code it looks like
we have interesting alright so we we do
have a margin up here on the header okay
let's give us some more space here
this way this actually might be a little
bit more difficult because we don't our
containing div does not go all the way
up to the top we have we have this
margin here or is that padding
I think it's padding yeah yeah the green
is padding all right let's see how it
looks I don't think it's gonna work but
I think it's worth a shot if not we may
have to go to my alternate solution okay
alright so using them what's already
display flex wonderful let's see if we
can use a line a line self let's see
what we get
okay so if we Center it see this is what
I was afraid of we're centering it and
we we're centering it based on a div
that stops here so if we were to let's
say get rid of this padding top the
centering works and you know what I I
think we can get rid of that padding on
the top let's shift the screen down just
to make sure that it still looks okay I
think it looks fine without the padding
and if we need to add anything we can
deal with that at some point we can just
change the height but I think that works
so we need to go in to the components or
the CSS files that are attached
components we need to add a line let's
go back down here we need to add a line
self-center and then we also need to
take that padding at top padding off of
the header and I think that should fix
it all right so let's go to our code now
and fix this so it should be let me
close this it should be in our layout
let's check layout first see if that
gives us that header component
let's let's shrink this a bit area hmm
maybe not
yes we have the footer we have yeah okay
he's an app bar yeah it should be an app
bar let's check this out
right so let's check out the classes now
on app bar we have them up here so we're
doing some inline and if I'm going too
fast please feel free to to ask
questions
I'll definitely go back and slow down a
bit so we have these styles that are
JavaScript but they look like CSS and
they're right here in our component
which is nice because we have one place
where we can edit everything it's very
modular we could use this component
elsewhere and you know the styles will
stay the same but in this case you can
see we have our app bar and which acts
as a class right and then we have this
padding top so let's just get rid of
that and then we'll have what we need
we'll have one half of what we need so
we've gotten rid of that padding on the
top and then let's sum this menu button
this is where we've switched up the
height here and set a new height at that
breakpoint but we're just going to
remove that so that way we no longer
have that change of height on that
element and then we're also gonna add
that aligned self we need the camel case
here because if we were to put that - in
in JavaScript it's going to interpret
that as like a math operator right it's
gonna say it's it's a minus sign we
don't want that but then we can put in
quotation marks we can say Center and
this should give us what we want in case
I missed something so we're going to
save that go back and I'm gonna refresh
so it just gets rid of everything that
we done in dev tools oops and I just
realized that I my image over on the
other side my video may have been
blocking things let me
oh no I think it was okay and only got
blocked anything but anyway now all that
has gotten rid of and we could see hey
it looks fine it looks centered and it's
still it's a circle and no no longer an
oval let's verify that it still works on
a smaller screen yep
yeah it works we haven't messed anything
up excellent and I think we ended up
with a little bit less code than what we
started with which is awesome
always good thing all right great
so that's the the first thing fixed and
I'm just going to go ahead through the
process of committing this change so
let's do a get status right and I'm
gonna move my image back down here for
now so we can see we've changed that
components that at bar J s component
we've edited that that's what we wanted
adds we're going to do a get add we put
a dot that just adds everything if we
had one only wanted to add a specific
you know file or set of files we could
list them out there but I just usually
use the dot by default because most of
the time I do want to commit everything
that's there so now that's ready to be
committed and I'm gonna do yarn CM for a
particular project we have a little
automated things set up to help us make
a good commit message but if you don't
have that set up in your project which
much projects don't you could just type
in git commit with the M flag and type
in your commit message and that'll do
the same thing so what we've done is
where we fixed a bug okay and I'm gonna
write a little description and fix it's
a menu buses
[Music]
let's see menu button hovers
when you think of me always always
circular okay that works that really was
what we set out to do right let me I
don't think this affects any open issues
no it doesn't okay now what's gonna run
through Auto formatting everything based
on our es lint rules and it's going to
run our unit tests and our end-to-end
tests and if everything passes then it
will commit and we have some we're
passing but we do have some warning so
that may be the next thing that we fix
because those warnings are ugly we want
to want to get rid of them let me know
on my screen it looks like the video and
audio are out of sync let me know if it
looks like that to you all
all right great so this all work now I
can do a git push and that one I'll be
available at the github repo that's
linked in the description okay great
usually if you're committing things if
you using it to track or any version
control system you want to commit often
because each time you commit it's like a
save point right that you can always go
back to so if you wait too long to
commit you might reach a point where
something messes up and if you had to
revert you'd lose a lot of your work so
if you know it only takes you know a
minute or less to commit
but it could potentially save you a lot
of time okay so it looks like some of
you are seeing a delay and some of you
aren't all right the delays getting
better now it still looks like it's a
little bit off but it's definitely
better than it was hmm okay I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna worry about it now
then because it's pretty close it was
off I wonder if it was just off when I
was running through all those tests
anyway I'm gonna check my timer okay we
got about 10 minutes so if you've asked
any questions in the chat in about 10
minutes I will get to those we're gonna
move on now and let's deal with these
errors so I'm gonna pull this up just so
we can see them and let's pull this to
the side for a second all right so what
I like to go whenever you get error
messages I find it's helpful to go all
the way up to the top because often the
top error message is usually easier to
comprehend and that'll get you to the
root of the problem sometimes if you fix
that the later messages go away I'm
sorry it's a warning message not an
error so that's where we're gonna start
so it says a failed prop type the prop
on open is marked as required and
swipeable drawer but its value is
undefined okay so if you remember
yesterday we switched over to that
swipeable drawer component but we
evidently didn't put the on open prop so
I didn't realize that that was required
so let's do that now so this should be
in our drawer component let's close this
out
I can close this out yeah I don't need
to save that we've gone through that
already let's go to our components
folder and we're gonna go to drawer a s
and we'll scroll down here to where we
have that swipeable drawer you see we
have on close but we don't have on open
so I'm not sure let's just try to put
toggle drawer toggle drawer in here as
what's gonna happen I don't know if
that'll mess it up but we'll see maybe
it'll make our errors go away the next
time so definitely want to test this
though okay
all right everything looks fine looks
like it's working
let me refresh just to verify that our
changes are there it should Auto refresh
but doesn't hurt to be sure okay looks
like everything's working so let's just
run our tests and which tests were this
it's where I end to end test let me see
let's check our package.json and see
what command will run our tests and and
I think this right end-to-end test so
let's go with e to e so let's run the e
on e to e to run our test again and see
if we get any errors or if we get
different errors I'm ok with that
all right wonderful you know what let's
run our unit test as well just to be
sure
all right great so it looks like all our
test paths
oh there we go did we get Sun I guess I
didn't notice those oh but we are
getting different warnings so those
warnings that we had before are not
there so we did fix that the key
keyboard focus provided to the class's
property is not implemented in button
base you can only override one of the
falling root disabled focus visible all
right let's search for this keyboard
focus throughout our whole project and
find out where it's at because we're not
getting yeah it's not telling us where
that is we can try to look at our
console here and see if we get a message
we are getting a message but it doesn't
tell us where it's at either so let's go
back into our code and we're gonna go
here and this is Visual Studio code so
if we click on that magnifying glass
icon then we can search throughout our
entire project so let's do that
all right so in our inverted button
component we have this keyboard focused
mmm okay all right this makes sense now
let's let's go to that inverted button
component
okay I was a little bit afraid this
would happen so a while ago we wanted to
create a different type of button so we
took we went into node modules and we
found the code for button that was that
was being used by material UI so we took
all that code we copied and pasted it
and modified it directly and created
this inverted button component what I
was worried about was that the changes
would break it it didn't break it but we
are getting warnings so let's see what
we need to do then keyboard focus
all right so saying keyboard focused
we're gonna do shadow
focus visible alright maybe
maybe we'll change it to focus visible
and see if that that works
so let's go with
focus visible and let's make sure this
is the only place where we've used it
and it looks like yes these other places
won't really matter they're just the
names of classes we created we could
have named them anything all right so
I'm gonna save that if this is the only
thing that I need to change for this
still to work I'm gonna be surprised but
let's run through and which tests where
these
well these came from our unit test all
right so let's let's rerun our unit test
see what we get now
we could just check the console refresh
the page but this way we can stay on the
same screen there we go
so now we've we've fixed that so you see
we run your own unit and you know it's
definitely the tests that are making the
audio and video out of sync as I just
looked over briefly and I could see
what's out of sync
okay cool so it looks like this works we
can also verify over here cool so we're
no longer getting that warning here
either we could check the buttons yep
the buttons you know they're working all
these these buttons are these aren't
using these ones are using the inverted
button cool all right so that works
let's see alright so I was just clicking
just to see if we get anything happen
when I clicked and nothing happened when
we click or hover so I think I think
that's good let's do a git add my timer
is almost up so this would be the last
thing we do before I go to the questions
and
all right so let's do another fix and
what was the first thing that we did
let's just say some say address
Mornington console from A to E you I
update this does affect an open issue I
believe I created an issue for this so
let's go over to our repo and check this
issue
so this is our repo open already to an
old issue that's already fixed and this
is the swipeable drawer error that we'd
like to fix and that is issue 125 so
we're gonna go back over here and we'll
say yes it does affect an open issue and
then we'll add a reference to issue 1 2
5 right and we'll press enter now to run
through everything it all should work
and then we'll push that up to github so
I'm gonna set my timer now for 5 minutes
and I'll answer questions for the next 5
minutes let me get my there we go I
couldn't see the chat for a second I'm
gonna scroll all the left to the top so
whoever asked the questions first your
questions will be answered first if I
can't answer
David us what are the prerequisites
before watching this dream anybody can
watch the stream and if you don't know
what's happening just ask questions I'll
do my best to explain but really to get
the most out of the stream it would be
helpful if you had some knowledge of
HTML CSS JavaScript if you really want
to get a lot out of this stream if you
have knowledge of react that would also
be helpful so I like to make this as a
beginner friendly as possible so I think
depending on where you're at in terms of
your experience level you will get
different things out of this stream but
hopefully everybody can get something
out of it but you know that's that's
gonna change so just know that no matter
where you're at if you ever get confused
just ask I'd be happy to go back over
something that I had done and explain it
in a little bit more detail and yeah
some in certain streams are different
some streams we just work with CSS some
streams we work with sequel some streams
we work with WordPress so you know there
are some shoes who do really basic stuff
and some where we do more complicated
things so it kind of just depends on
what we're doing as well in terms of
like what you what background will help
you the most
alright I'm gonna do a git push there we
go let's go back to the chat
scrubs I guess that's how I'm
pronouncing that says I'd suggest
watching at any level it's good to see
how things are done by other devs yeah
yeah thanks for bringing that up I think
that's a good thing that you know even
if you don't exactly understand what's
going on on the screen in terms of the
code it it may be helpful just to see
the process or you know just to hear the
opinions of the other devs in the chat
as well there's a lot of a lot of
knowledge there Julio says use get
integrated forget add and get and commit
basic commands I've never I've never
done that before I maybe have to check
that out
Nikki says use control B to toggle that
sidebar menu on and off control B okay
off to check that out let me try right
now all right it's not working no all
right it's not working for me let me see
what there we go
you know what I have the Adam keyboard
shortcut setup so it's it's actually for
me on a Mac command and then I don't
know the slash that also has the pipe
operator above him the [ __ ] I can't
remember what's it for word and with the
backslash but anyway that's why mine may
be a bit different
I always forget to use them Julio says
is a good idea react for single page app
or better I go with angular it really
depends on what you're more comfortable
with and if there's some specific
feature of angular or react that you
would like react works great is a single
page app and actually even further as a
progressive web app so if you use you
know create react app it will be really
it'll set you up to have a progressive
web app pretty much right off the bat I
don't know enough about angular to
really make a recommendation for it
though
I hope hope we hope what I'm not it's
hopw II says hey Jesse amazing stuff
you've got here may I ask you what
exactly does the json syntax to do i
mean how are the commands define and
everything okay so this uh this package
JSON file it's it's for using NPM node
package manager so basically it's just a
set of descriptions and it tracks all
the packages that your project uses so
that if somebody else wants to to work
on it they can download all the code
without having to download all the node
modules but then they have a record of
which node modules are used and so they
can just install those and NPM will
automatically like it'll just read this
it'll know what to install and you can
get working and then in this scripts
part of it you can just define kind of
like little shortcuts to use so you can
type in like npm dev and it'll do all
this stuff so instead of typing all this
out you just make this little shortcut
dev and then it will run and you can
make you know whatever you want for for
all your shortcuts so that's kind of a
really quick overview but hopefully that
helps a little bit okay my timer went up
again so I'm gonna go do some more code
there's only one more question left
though so this is priyanka asked which
is better adams sublime or Visual Studio
I've never used sublime I do like Adam
but I have switched over to visual
studio it seems a bit quicker
so I definitely like it but I can't say
anything about sublime because I've
never used it though but I think you'd
be fine going with any of them they're
gonna they're gonna work well okay all
right let's go back let's set this
Pomodoro timer and let's see we can see
now that this is referenced so that
commit we just made as reference here
I'm gonna close the issue because it's
been fixed and if anybody checks out
that issue you know they'll be able to
see like this addressed it and they can
go check out how how we fixed it
all right let's go back and oh ok here's
another thing so when we updated the
padding around grid items was taken away
so you can see here all these buttons
are actually encased in the grid
components so we need to put back some
padding and add them in here so let's
check that out let's go to our component
so we have this hero component let's
take out drawer here take this out too
just to make some space
there we go here Oh so hero is where we
have these buttons so we've set up so
that these buttons are actually like
constants and we move them in and there
they're optional so this is where the
actual code is for the buttons so the
primary button is the one on the top and
then we have the two lower buttons here
as our secondary and tertiary buttons
and then you can see depending on what
props are passed into the hero component
we will display you know a certain
number of buttons so what we want to do
though is for these grid items we want
to have some some spacing so let's try
to put I'm not exactly sure which part
of the grid needs the spacing needs to
go on so let's try to put it on that top
grid container and let's go spacing and
we'll say equals let's try 16 at first
okay so we're gonna give it a value of
16 and see what happens usually in
material design you the values are like
8 you know 8 or 16 for padding is almost
always what you get hey there we go all
right so that ended up being an easy fix
so basically what happened between the
older version of material UI and this
newer version is that they used to have
by default I believe it was a spacing of
16 since it's 16 pixels but it was
messing some things up so they decided
to go with a default of no spacing and
then if you want spacing you put it in
so that definitely makes sense but if
you were counting on that spacing before
and now it's not there it messes it up
but see now we have our spacing back
this looks pretty much exactly like it
did before as far as I can remember
awesome that was an easy fix
great let's go with I don't think I had
an issue open for this yet but I guess
it's worth it's a check yeah nothing
nothing for that open so I'm going to
take my own advice about get commits and
we're gonna commit often I've been a
little bit lazy about committing lately
and I've just been making huge commits
where I basically work all day and then
commit at the end and that's not a good
idea it almost I almost ruined a lot of
work on my presentation for the talk
that I gave over the weekend which if
you check out my youtube channel you can
watch the talk if you'd like but my
presentation I almost like lost
everything because I didn't commit and
so now I'm going to try to commit more
often it's one of those things that you
always know you should do but sometimes
you just get lazy with it so let's do it
get status it's always nice to get
status just to verify what you've done
has actually been done and nothing you
haven't inadvertently changed a file
that you didn't realize that you changed
so we'll do a git add yarn cm and let's
say fix and I'm just going to do a hero
button spacing
all right and that should all pass
through all the tests I mean we've
really only changed such a small amount
it should be fine
and while that's going let's go back in
here and see what else we have going on
I know of one other issue that we could
work on but while we're on this page we
may as well check these look fine it's
actually something I've been meaning to
do as well like right now we have these
cards and their YouTube videos and you
click them they play automatically which
is really nice but I don't like loading
the YouTube videos on the home page
because it actually slows down the load
time so I would like to come up with
some sort of solution where we could
still have a very similar functionality
but not have to actually load the
YouTube video so I'm okay with some sort
of lazy loading or you know perhaps we
don't actually load it until this is
clicked on so we could kind of make our
own play button when you click it and
then it Auto plays the video
it loads and auto plays there'll be a
little bit more delay when you're
actually trying to play the video but
many users may not even try to click the
video so we'll see we'll see how it goes
but I definitely I don't want to remove
all the videos because I think it's nice
to have them right there but we got to
do something so that we don't mess up
our load times trying to load in all
that iframe stuff for the videos all
right so I'd like to go to the English
faculty page
oh no you know what our our snapshot
failed because it's it changed so we're
doing our unit tests it automatically
makes snapshots and we didn't update our
snapshot after we we ran that so let's
go ahead and update that snapshot now
okay great so now that we've done that
we can go back and run this yarn cm with
the retry flag so now it should just go
back in and it should work this time
we'll check in on it in a second oh okay
so we actually have problem here all
right it says to lower case is undefined
see if we can figure out where this
issue is what is this the faculty list
pages I think I know what the problem is
did we get an error again
is this it's still showing the air with
that test
all right for some reason our snapshot
didn't update so what we can do to fix
that is go into our snapshots and check
out we can see this snapshot is the one
that's not working we can delete the
snapshot and then run this again and
that should create the snapshot properly
this time so let's try that and while
that's running let's go to that page
where we're getting the air and that's
the faculty list page be sure if you
have to go in and delete your unit
snapshot that you actually delete the
snapshot and not the unit test itself
they have the same name except for the
stuff snapshot at the end so I've done
this multiple times where I've
accidentally deleted the entire unit
test in and that's kind of like it's a
pain I can do I can just go into github
a copy and paste the unit test I guess I
could go into the trash or recycle bin
and restore but it is just kind of a
pain so we can see that that work now so
it created a new snapshot and you know
occasionally I have to do that it's
pretty rare though all right so let's
see what else has changed so we do want
to commit that snapshot so we're gonna
do a git add as well before we run this
you are in cm retry
so if we just would have run the rnc em
retry without committing that snapshot
then what could happen is somebody who's
trying to pull that that update would
then get the same error that we just did
with our snapshots right so we want to
make sure we commit it commit them both
all right so that's their push that to
github now in this faculty list here's
what I think is happening let's see if
it's if it's the case I think maybe our
imports are not we're not importing
things properly or potentially something
that were like below in the child
components maybe is not being imported
properly so first we're gonna check here
in the faculty list and I'm just going
to glance through this and see I'm
looking for anything that we're
importing from material I was okay so
it's not here so I'm guessing it's in
this faculty list item component so
let's grab that component shut our test
folder so let's check the faculty list
item component and here we go I think
this is our issue so in the latest
version of material I we don't import
things all together in one line like
this we would import them all separately
so here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
grab these and I'm gonna copy and paste
these and let's get rid of these and get
ready
and for this one we're just going to
grab the card right and then for this
one we're gonna grab card actions and
then for this one we're gonna say card
content and then now we can say actions
content alright so that way that was
pretty quick and it looks like we're not
actually even using card so let's get
rid of that we can tell from this wiggly
line it's gonna say that it's defined in
every use so let's get rid of that but
now we can see that instead of importing
all these together from card the the
file card we're going to import card
actions from card actions we're going to
import card content from card content so
they're all separated out now let's make
sure we're not doing the same thing now
it looks it looks good so let's save
that and if I was right which I'm not
very often but if I was right then the
error should be gone so let's check it
out yay air is gone all right cool the
only reason that I was able to figure
that out so quickly is because we we
dealt with or at least i yesterday
before i streamed spent a long time
dealing with very similar errors so it
was still fresh in my mind and I knew
what that meant
if I had probably gotten that error you
know a week later I may not have
remembered it all right so now that's
great we fixed that error so we probably
should commit that but what I really
wanted to show you all is this we have
this iframe that's coming through and
we're seeing the code and not the actual
iframe so we need to check out see
what's going on here why is the video
not displaying and why are we getting
the code there what I suspect is that
I'm I'm not bringing in the the content
like as HTML so we'll check in in that
this will be our faculty je s component
in the pages folder so we'll check that
in just a second but let's commit our
fix that we did here get status let's do
a git add and a yarn cm and let's say to
fix and we're gonna fix fix imports
we're gonna fix no nope there we go so
it may be worthwhile to bill and check
all the imports and all of our
components I thought I had already taken
care of them all evidently I didn't so
while it's still fresh in my mind that
might be a good thing to do I don't know
if I'll do that on the stream it's just
gonna be kind of repetitive and not
probably not very educational all right
wonderful get push all right so let's
get get this out of here
and let's get this out of here we've
already done our work there and let's
find that faculty is
so here's all their pages so a faculty
died Jas page and here we go so we're in
our render method here and interesting
okay let me check that again let's let's
look up with the mark-up actually is
here video embed oh I see
interesting all right here's what's
happening this is being brought in with
with quotation marks around it let's go
over to our wordpress installation and
see what data is there I want to see
where those quotation marks are being
added in so go to WP Franciscan
University this is where WordPress
installation is right now great I was
already logged in so that's awesome and
we need to find faculty so you want to
go in here to faculty and find our
English faculty there we go
all right so there we go that's it
so in our actual code we have these
quotation marks I think no no we don't
why is it like this all right let's do
some editing of the code here and see if
we can get the video to appear properly
hmm okay all right
so I'm hoping that this will will make
it work now unfortunately what I'll have
to do is maybe get somebody in here to
like a student worker to manually make
these changes or we could come up with
some way to change that programmatically
within our component now that I will
have some students working on this I'm a
little bit more open tech to manually
editing this data okay
let's go back here and refresh see what
we get
interesting
oh I see
I check this out within our component
we're searching for anything with this
source attribute and we're replacing it
we're adding this we're prepending this
franciscan dot e-d-u
we need to do this for images but we
don't want to do this for iframes so
this is going to be this is going to be
interesting
let me know what you all think yeah let
me see okay so here's our problem and
I'd like your advice on the solution
here so the problem is we do need to
replace some of not replace we need to
prepend
a URL onto these source attributes for
images but we don't want to do that for
iframes so what would be the best way to
do that
I'm thinking maybe a regular expression
but this is going to be another instance
where my regular expression skills are
not good enough to make this happen
without without some research
hmm
all right let me look and see what would
you all think Johnny instance says do a
ternary true do this use video element
Johnny instance since yes regex needed
yeah you know what maybe trying to think
about how to create the issues so that
it'll make sense off to think about how
to explain this in an issue
I'll make the issue if anybody is good
with regex and wants to try it out
you'll feel free otherwise at least I
will remember what the issue is and then
I can spend some time researching
regular expressions to see how I could
fix this problem I don't really want to
do research on the stream it's just not
not very exciting watching me read
things
I wonder if we can take what we're doing
with a CV link and just adapt it
actually let's do it still it's it's
worth a try let's just edit this see if
we can get it to work
okay so instead of CV link what we're
looking for then is iframe and instead
of a href we're just looking for mmm
that's what we're looking for maybe we
can get rid of this
we don't need this all right now we just
need to let me change this iframe regex
all right well the problem though is we
still have that replace happening you
know what maybe we'll have to yeah well
um we're gonna have to do another
regular expression for where we're
getting the image thing and actually my
timer just went up so let me take a
break and go back to the chat answer
some more questions and then let me know
what you all want if you think the
streams already gone on long enough
we'll stop here or if you really want to
see if we can fix this then I all extend
it a bit longer and we'll see if we can
fix it
okay Nikki made a good point earlier
when we were talking about different
editors so saying visual studio does not
equal visual studio code so yeah I think
a lot of times were just kind of talking
you shorten it and say visual studio
instead of visual studio code I like to
say vs code it just seems faster but
yeah visual studio is a much bigger
program much more powerful but overkill
for what we do
vs code is very similar to things like
atom or sublime it's built with electron
so yeah definitely a different thing for
Janka says could you please tell me how
to get an internship after two years my
graduation is it possible I tell you
that I'm not sure I've never you know
pursued an internship but there are
internship opportunities out there if
we're gonna look for internship
opportunities you know after graduating
I would to be honest with you I do a
little Google search first I'm guessing
that you've already done that so I'm
sorry that's probably not very helpful
but I I don't have experience with that
if anybody else has experience with
getting internships after you've already
been in college please let let Priyanka
mad Duchess says does it work to add the
snapshots and unit tests into another
folder for easier management or does
that affect performance I mean I guess
you could add them into another folder I
don't know if it would hurt the
performance okay sorry Nikki all right
now I see what you're saying
okay sorry so yeah we we do have the
tests separated out so alright we have
our test folder and then within the test
folder we have the snapshots folder so
they are separated like that but the
problem is like when you have them both
open or like if I have it closed and I
just go in and say like alright I'm
gonna remove my snapshot sometimes I
accidentally remove the wrong one it
happens
Nikki asked with the Google doodle for
today is Michael says this dr. Virginia
apgar's 109 day cool
I don't I don't know who dr. Virginia
Apgar is but maybe I should know
let's check it out cool
it's app car like the score they give
babies I think it is now it's coming
back to me since I've had fork kids
should know this cool uh yeah I'd love
to find out more about that
okay yeah it is the the Apgar test cool
for babies
okay so Carlos is saying in regard to
the regular expression stuff you say
maybe adapt another constant as like CV
regex but for the videos okay so that's
what we're doing and pull it on the
replace method
Charbel Sarkis is how do you select the
same occurrence of the text twice and
edit at the same time replace after it
do a replace after the last replace if
the regex doesn't match and nothing is
going to change okay let's see
hmm
yeah I don't think all right well let's
just let's just do this and see if what
I think is going to happen will happen
which is we're not gonna it's not gonna
do what we want it to do but let's just
give it a shot you know the iframe here
and then let me grab
describe this
and then what we want to do is for this
source we're gonna put in h2 or I'm
sorry not h2 because we're gonna want
yeah whatever's after that and then here
okay
we actually
yeah I can I can bring this down even
further
okay it's still gonna be the second one
okay
and just to to make sure this is going
all right let's just add that in so
we'll know if it worked
you're fresh
and let's see
okay it looks like this it did not work
so our replace here did not work
maybe that messed it up
try again
he
that didn't work either
alright let's add in
it's not gonna work including today
all right still not working
let me see
okay John Hanson says you may be able to
write the ternary into the same argument
where you replace the URL for the
University since it's already finding
that
Julio is asking about I is on 2018 I'm
not I'm not sure where you're asking
we're not using is okay let's check this
out
okay so we're trying to find the source
here
the problem with putting the turn area
in here is that I'm not grabbing
anything other than that SRC so there's
there's nothing for me to say like if I
mean maybe
yeah I'm not sure about the ternary I
think it would have to be a regex thing
again like we look grab ngosource
[Music]
but we're not gonna grab it if it has
the word youtube in it or something like
that
I wonder
what if we can do this I wonder if
that'll work
ah no
what did I do
all right this works but unfortunately
it'll get rid of any anything in that
image sag
all right let me get rid of this then
and we're rid of this all right let me
explain why did this did so instead of
just looking for the source attribute I
said like okay I'm gonna look for you
know image with source attribute which
works but it'll also rewrite like if
there were other attributes so let's
just let's check it out and see if there
even were other attributes in this case
no there weren't all it's just the alt
attribute was missing actually you know
what I think there's a better way to do
this and still keep our alt attributes
or whatever attributes we have so let's
do this we're gonna make it cost and
we're gonna say this is the image reg X
and let's create we're gonna get rid of
the CV link stuff
we're going to get rid of it here we're
gonna replace this a tag with image and
image F so that's gonna be all the stuff
inside the href and then actually we're
not gonna have an ending image tag right
no we won't
what we'll have then it's just this
we're not gonna need this so this will
be our href and then this will be all
the other attributes at the end so then
we go down here and we can say we're
gonna replace this all with get rid of
CV link get rid of CV link let's add an
image I add in our image tag we'll place
this href with the source the second
section there is what we want for our
source and then we're not gonna add in
our other stuff here instead we're gonna
put in we're just gonna grab whatever
else is there which would be four so
we're gonna say this is going to be four
and then we don't want any of this we
want that and then we can remove whoops
almost forget that so we want to combine
the
in here hopefully that space won't mess
it up mmm yeah let's leave it like that
okay and we will get rid of this for now
or let's just comment it out for now
okay now let's see if that works
no I what did we get the image source
[Music]
okay not too bad we didn't get what
exactly what we wanted though but
or maybe we didn't get anything maybe it
didn't work at all yeah you know what it
didn't work because we look for the
wrong thing Oh someone noticed there is
an extra okay yep
good luck Nikki
dang
it's not working
mmm
I'm messing up something in this regular
expression for the image so it's not
actually getting oops sorry see all
right let's try it now yes all right see
an image source that works and then it
also has the oh yes all right awesome
so that worked okay cool the only thing
I'm thinking that maybe might not work
exactly right is if in the markup
they've put a lot of attributes before
the source in that case it's not that it
won't work it's just that those Astra
buttes might not actually get added in
at the end but for now this works and it
does preserve anything after which is
definitely better than what we had
before
and our videos now work so that's pretty
awesome I think it's awesome all right
John said you made it look so easy I
don't know how I just did that sometimes
like you know what it's just it you just
get this light bulb in your you know a
moment where it's like I I have it
occasionally that happens I think I just
got like in the zone you know and it's
just my brain was just working I don't
even know why because I'm starving right
now I was about to give up cuz I was
just so hungry and I was thinking like I
can't even think but alright I guess I'm
okay under pressure then Carlos says yay
don't know what you did but awesome good
coding all right cool yeah so let me
take just a second to explain what I did
as best I can and then then we'll finish
up any questions with any questions you
have and we'll all in the stream okay so
here's what I did basically so we quit
using this
just get rid of that right so we made
this regular expression which all it's
doing is just searching for something
right so this whole constant is just a
search and we've just given it certain
parameters so that it searches for and
finds exactly what we want so what I'm
searching for is this particular string
which is like the beginning of an image
tag but I want to find the image tag
that also has a source equals in it with
a what am I thinking for with a
quotation mark right with a double quote
at the beginning right so assuming it
finds that then what it's going to do is
it's going to save whatever comes
between the first quote the second quote
as a variable and we're going to be able
to access that variable by using dollar
sign to write that's the second thing in
there I'm not sure if this is proper of
regex terminology but this is how I'm
explaining I'm understanding it from
JavaScript world okay so now everything
that's in that source attribute gets
saved for us and then everything after
the source attribute but before the
ending tag in the image tag will get
saved as this other variable that we're
going to be able to access as dollar
sign for because it's the one two three
fourth set of parentheses here then
basically we're finding that ending to
this and so altogether with this regular
expression we're getting an entire image
tag and this is going to say we want to
search globally I believe so correct me
if I'm wrong with this so this is global
so we're going to find every occurrence
of this not just the first occurrence
and then we want it to be case
insensitive so just in case you know
somebody decides to make the image tag
capitalized it still should work right
now when we go down here we're getting
all that content that we're grabbing
from WordPress so everything that we see
here we're getting all that content and
then we are replacing parts of it so
once we get down to this replace we're
going to search so the first parameter
of that replace is a search for that
regular expression so we're searching
for any of those image tags right but
then we want to replace that entire
image tag with the second parameter and
so the second parameter is an image tag
but we're adding in this Franciscan edu
URL because that's where that image
lives right so in order to grab the
image we need that and then we're just
adding in whatever was the in there
originally right that dollar sign too
and then we're just tacking on any other
attributes like an alt tag or a title
tag that may have been a part of that
image and then we're closing our image
tag all right so basically it's a find
and replace but we're just doing some
fancy stuff with the find does that make
sense
Aniki says go to another one of those
pages is the iframe also enclosed by
quotes there oh you know what that's a
good that's a good idea we did manually
edit some of that so that the iframe was
enclosed in quotes yeah so potentially
potentially we we could programmatically
do that I'm gonna and I'm gonna just
kind of stop with that now and then I'll
look through a few other ones and see if
we come upon that issue again I'll
either manually change it or I'll add
another one of these regular expressions
for that particular scenario where we
have the iframe within quotations
so yeah but you're right that that may
be an issue
Matt Dutchess says thanks for making
regex
less scary and breaking it down for us
oh yeah no problem
it's still scary for me I just when I
need it to work that's the only time I
use it I guess and and really you know
we had a pull request that gave us this
you know I didn't come up with this but
then after seeing this example I was
able to understand what it did and then
was able to do this based on that so
when it comes to regular expressions I
think that's the best if I see an
example I can usually edit it right but
if I try to come up with a regular
expression completely on my own it's
rough it's really hard so maybe that's a
good way to approach regular expressions
try to find something that's doing
something similar to what you want and
then maybe make make a few edits it
could be a nice shortcut to get to where
you need to go alright my I may as well
start the process of
this change while I'm doing questions so
let's get started get status yep
get a yarn see em fix so what are you
going to fix I have video faculty pages
yep there we go that's cool that's
definitely something I didn't think I'd
be able to fix during the stream so well
that's the one it's thing let me finish
up with some of these questions and then
I might leave and get something to eat I
might finish up my workday from home
because I'm so hungry
and it's so tough when you're on a diet
you can't just like find whatever and
just scavenge it you know although I
tell you what like right now it's taking
a lot of my willpower to not just eat
like whatever the next thing is edible
that I could find
michael creo says you have four kids and
don't know the Apgar test what once I
saw the baby in the thing like it kind
of like refresh my memory about Apgar
but well my youngest is a year and a
half old now so it's been a year and a
half since I've probably even heard that
and to be honest with you when my
youngest was born my wife had a lot of
problems and had to have a lot of
doctor's appointments and surgeries so
that I like took a lot of time off of
work and drove her around all her stuff
and took care of the kids so that's kind
of like all blur and so I was much less
worried about Cordelia my youngest then
I was about my wife so anyway that's
probably why I don't remember
someone asked about my visual studio
code theme and Nicki says it's it is
SETI
so yeah SETI is the theme that I'm using
I've been using this for years and years
like even back when I started with Adam
which was I don't know like for at least
four years ago I think it was I was
started using Adam like really early on
so not too long after it was first first
came out so I've been using this theme
for ever
Michael Creole says is the a.href search
hard-coded because not all CV link start
with the href that was messing with me
let me think
you know what I haven't really tested
this a lot to make sure it works
everywhere but it should work so if the
it doesn't necessarily have to start
with href I believe that as long as href
is contained somewhere it will still
work I think that's what this period is
going in here
but I'm not a higher percent sure that
was just my assumption otherwise we
could have just taken this period out
and left a space in and it would work
okay yeah that's it so I need there were
no other questions there in the chat
thank you all so much for hanging in
here with me for so long oh okay
also asking about the font it's the fire
or fear of font for Visual Studio code
so Fira so search for the search for
that font for Visual Studio code and
should be able to get that it has the it
does cool stuff like so when you do an
arrow function it combines it right so
it does some stuff like that alright so
I'm gonna end the stream and get
something to eat before I fall over here
and yeah tomorrow it's a Friday already
wow this week he's just gone so so
quickly anyway yeah I'll try to do a
stream tomorrow and not sure what we'll
be working on we'll see maybe we'll find
some more problems and fix those
tomorrow but thanks again for watching
and until tomorrow have a wonderful day